uh i just don't know what to say anymore
sometimes ian
i i'm rarely lost for words but i cannot
believe this uh
a populist measure with no scientific
basis at all
nice to hear jonathan van tam the king
of metaphors
talk about his garden shed but that's
nothing to do with what we're on about
as i said yesterday and i've said ad
nauseum
we got the best ventilated space in
hospitality
uh and sort of a hangover from the days
of smoking
and it's not been taken into
consideration at all they're talking
about large venues what's a large venue
maybe what they're going to come up with
next will be some sort of twist whereby
small clubs will be okay and large ones
won't but large ones often have the
ceiling space
and and the controls under and the
measures in place
because they've got the sort of
economies of scale to do so
it beggars belief i cannot believe it
i mean you've said peter just there that
uh you think this is a bit of a populist
move i mean
there's not really much scientific basis
for this is um it's not as if lots of
old
unvaccinated old people go to nightclubs
i'm the only one of those
there is no science in this uh we did uh
we commissioned along with other
nightclub uh
live venue operators and other trade
bodies
um as wide ranging as orchestras uh all
got together last year and
and got the institute of occupational
medicine to
show us the way through this and of
course we expected to be back last
september another world
but of course we accept it we have a
heart we understand when things are
going terribly wrong
it's right to stay close but what the
iom said is
that the way you deal with this
scientifically
is that you do risk assessments and that
won't be on a sector basis
it'll be on a venue basis with the sort
of things like air changes and
how you know sort of how much space
there is and where they might need to
reduce the capacity in certain areas
that's science this isn't it's populism
uh well so apologies for the language
there peter um
i can understand uh why why you are
frustrated um
i mean it's been suggested in one or two
quarters that uh the government is
trying to do this it's a way of urging
young people to go and get vaccinated
you know it's a stick rather than a
character you must feel pretty put out
that it's your industry that is uh
that is having to be used in this way
yeah listen
i i'm not an unreasonable person i
understand why people want to get the
young vaccine
uh you know but he won't do it just by
saying we can't go to nightclubs
probably only 10 of people aged 18 to 30
regularly go to nightclubs
so it's not going to work why victimize
us
this is the point i have and i think
what we are is that we are sort of
you know we're not relevant from the
point of view of number of votes really
because we're not that big an industry
but we are hugely relevant for messaging
and i think that's where this has come
in
that's why it's so disappointing and i'm
so animated about it
this time yesterday peter you said there
was a real risk that if these coveted uh
passports came in the business would go
under again
is that a serious threat hanging over
you i think the thing is i can't say for
definite what's going to happen and
whether people get vaccinated and
whether or not we won't be at a huge
disadvantage
to everybody else as it stands at the
moment if people don't pick up
uh and go and get vaccinated and we are
the only sector
that ends up having this put upon us
then frankly how on earth can we survive
people are just going to stay in the
pubs
they're going to go around there you
know other their friends houses they're
going to go into their halls of
residence
they're not going to sort of suddenly
stay in and look at their shoes at
midnight
and so this is why you know if we end up
almost by government dictat
having to ask for something that nobody
else has to ask for
that we are going to end up with such a
massive disadvantage
with nobody really coming in in any real
numbers and as
as we know with business most businesses
if they're taking takings drop around 20
percent
they're in trouble and uh it's the same
for us and our techies could drop 70 80
if people uh don't
get vaccinated in the numbers that the
government are hoping to
except at this time around unlike last
time
you won't have the furlough scheme to
fall back on come september
uh no furlough scheme rates disappearing
we've had no time to build
our cash pile up like others in
hospitality
have had uh you know and i don't want to
drag everybody into our fight by the way
in hospitality
it's i really just want to highlight the
fact that we've had absolutely no
real special help despite the fact that
we are seen as such a special case
and of course you're right the money is
going to be pouring out the plug hole
quicker than it's coming out the tap